we go
all right now do you see my slides great
yep great okay great all right yes
um yeah so
um thanks uh to the organizers and and
for you all uh for having me here it's
uh um I'm very happy to be able to join
with you uh to help celebrate Tony's
birthday
um you know yesterday uh Cynthia spoke
about the honor of going early in the
program but to me that seems like a lot
of pressure so I would actually like to
thank the organizers for the honor of
not going early in the program
um
uh but more seriously I also want to
thank the organizers and the Simons
Institute for uh setting up uh this
virtual option uh this hybrid hybrid
Workshop here
um
you know for for people who couldn't
make it uh like myself uh for whatever
reason you know their health their
ability families Health family
obligations teaching obligations
uh you know finances Visa issues uh it
it really helps uh those of us in those
situations uh you know engage with these
events and stay engaged with the
community so um really appreciate that
um all right so uh yeah what I wanted to
tell you about today is uh some of the
work that uh Tony has done with me and
and some stories about that um
so I often start my uh talks on proof
complexity with the slide that looks
something like this where I say you know
one of the things I like about proof
complexity is that it gives a way of
measuring the complexity of individual
instances of sat right so uh not not you
know oh
asymptotically as n goes to Infinity
there exists but no no I have you know
pigeonhole with pen pigeons and nine
holes you know what's the shortest
resolution proof right uh but this
statement is actually worded very
carefully uh and this we'll see in a
minute has something to do with 20 which
is okay you could take it positively as
there are other things I like about
proof complexity but also actually there
are some things I don't like about proof
complexity
um and uh
one of the things that I I don't usually
say is coming from sort of computational
complexity circuit complexity I actually
had a really time hard time uh
understanding and getting into proof
complexity
um and uh
I think
um you know for people who work on the
sort of computational or circuit
complexity side of things who don't do
proof complexity I think some of them
share some of the difficulties I had
when Tony first got me into this
um so some of the things are you know
why is proof complexity too hard for me
well one thing is it's too finicky about
proofs
and like okay of course it's proof
complexity what what else is it going to
be finicky about
um
you know what do you mean that the
pigeonhole principle and the onto
pigeonhole principle aren't just clearly
the same thing right or you know if I'm
encoding the pigeonhole principle in
semi-algebraic things why should it
matter whether I say the sum of x i j is
greater than or equal to one or for
Boolean variables you know I have this
product here these both say at least one
of the xij's must be one it's the same
principle like why should this matter
okay
so that's one thing uh and then the
other thing is it's like too syntactic
right you know coming from the circuit
complexity world is very semantic so you
say AC zero Fraga where every line is an
ac0 formula but as a function these are
all just tautologies every line is just
one so like what do you mean every line
is an AC zero
okay and and you know of course now I
understand what these things mean but
this was some of the difficulty I had I
had at the time
um and uh so you know this was sort of
uh when I met Tony I did a postdoc for a
couple years at utoronto
um and actually I want to pause here for
a minute because uh you know we've heard
lots of uh great things about 20's
technical work and we've heard lots of
individual personal stories but there's
something that Tony knows that I I kind
of want to make clear to all of us and
wasn't actually clear to me until I Was
preparing this talk so um yeah if we
could get the the oh yeah I see we have
the wide shot of the audience here so a
little audience participation a quick
show of hands
um raise your hand if you have ever been
mentored by Tony in any capacity
right and you know of course this is a
self-selected group we're all here to to
celebrate Tony's birthday but this is
not really an accident I mean Tony
really uh you know in addition to her
organizing in her work she's really
mentored a huge number of people and
really helped build up this community uh
and so I just wanted to take a moment to
sort of make that clear and thank her
for that um maybe with a round of
applause even is
um
yeah I mean you know this is this is no
small thing when I when I think of
people whose lists of mentees look like
this you know there are only maybe two
or three people that come to mind uh and
Tony is on that list so yeah
okay uh right so back to our story uh so
I was doing a postdoc at you Toronto I
think I was technically funded by Alan
Borden who I see in the audience here
thanks Alan uh but but uh Tony met with
me basically every week you know often
for two hours and as a as a professor
now I recognize sort of how precious
that time is and and uh really
appreciate even more than I did at the
time I mean
you know that was a that was a
significant investment in in me and our
work together that that had a real uh
impact on me for the whole rest of my
career uh and so I yeah thank you Tony
um
but there was a funny thing you know at
the time I kind of didn't like proof
complexity for for the reasons I said
and actually Tony I think as I remember
it she kind of tricked me into it
she said you know we'll just talk you
teach me something about algebraic
circuits I'll teach you something about
proof complexity we'll we'll see what we
come up with
uh and that worked
um and the the thing the the analogy
that this reminds me of is actually um
this is more or less the same way that
my wife tricked me into getting cats
um you know she said uh you know we
don't have to get cats let's let's just
go to the shelter and look we don't have
to get them and
um yeah for those of you who know you or
who don't uh you can imagine how that
turned out
um
yeah so
right so one of the things that I really
liked about when Tony was teaching me
proof complexity this is I sort of view
this as a very Tony view on proof
complete on on Fraga systems
um and I don't know where it originates
I mean maybe it's in a textbook
somewhere but I I view this as coming
you know sort of uh it's a Viewpoint
that at least Tony has told me she likes
and I really liked it and I sort of made
a lot of things click for me which is if
you want to talk about something like
bound to depth frega
you can think of it as its ordinary
Fraga which that made sense to me you
know that's like line by line proofs
sure fine
um but where there's a constant where
you only ever use the cut rule on
formulas that are expressed at you know
using that constant depth
and similarly for sea frega you know for
any syntactically defined circuit Class
C okay and this is still syntactic right
but somehow in my brain because this
wasn't talking about the syntax of every
line it was just talking about a
limitation on the cut rule this like
felt better to my circuit complexity
brain so this made some sense to me
all right
um and then we come to algebraic proofs
uh so we've heard actually a fair amount
about this uh which you know another
advantage of of me not going first
um so I'll go through it a little
quickly but just to to get to the story
here
um so you know every line in an
algebraic proof is of the form like f
equals zero uh where f is some
polynomial and there are various
complexity measures you can talk about
Max degree per line total number of
monomials number of lines but coming
from algebraic circuit complexity it's
like how are you going to prove a lower
bound on this what polynomial are even
going to prove lower bounds on like
every proof has so many lines are you
going to say well in every proof of this
thing there exists a line where I know
how to prove a circuit lower bound on
that like it just looks like a mess
um and so this was the point where you
know when Tony was teaching me about
algebraic circuit complexity we said
well what if what if there weren't lines
what if it was just one polynomial well
okay now that maybe is something we know
how to prove lower bounds on
um so this brings us to the ideal proof
system
um and by the way can you all see my
mouse
okay so uh I want to highlight up here
this actually goes back to some of
Tony's papers in the 90s and we'll we'll
come back to that in a few minutes but
um
so uh yeah let's see Sam introduced it
uh a little bit but I want to do it a
little slower so you know the the input
here is a system of polynomial equation
that's unsatisfiable say over an
algebraically closed field
um and the stone sots guarantees to you
that that if these equations F1 up to F
K have no Solutions uh that happens if
and only if there are other polynomials
G1 up to GK such that the sum of the
Fiji is identically one
right and you if you look at this
equation you see well if I could make
all the fi0 then I would get zero equals
one so that's a contradiction
so our idea was instead you introduce
these new placeholder variables y1 up to
YK corresponding to these uh your
original equations f
and you get a new polynomial where this
sort of sum of f IGI turns into this sum
of y i g i
uh and then we say a polynomial like
this which has two sets of variables X
and Y is an IPS certificate if when you
plug in the F's you get one so that's
like that's like this equation here
and that it should be in the ideal
generator by the Y's so what this
guarantees for you is that this when you
plug in the F's is in the ideal
generated by the F's
and now the nice that you know I've
written it a c because we're going to
think of it as a circuit but really it
could be any polynomial and so now the
nice thing is you there's just one
polynomial here and you can talk about
any measure of complexity of polynomials
that you like circuit size you know
bounded depth circuit size formula size
and so on
um and the default that we went with was
was algebraic circuit size with no
degree bound uh because that was the
version that that simulated extended
Fraga
um and actually so I didn't put this on
my slide but because someone I couldn't
see who it sounded a little bit to me
like Bruno but I'm not sure if he's
actually there ask this question about
um you know circuits versus proofs in
the IPS world if you get something like
um
uh you know formulas are as powerful as
general circuits then you immediately
get that formula IPS is equivalent to
General IPS right because you're just
talking about the circuit complexity of
of these things
okay
um
right so a little bit of the story of
this so you know I started in in
September of 2012 I think our first my
first meeting with Tony I think she was
traveling was like September 18th
and uh July 2013 I went back and looked
that was the earliest email I could find
that haven't had a draft of our ideal
proof system paper it wasn't complete
you know we had the result that Sam
mentioned that it implies VP uh you know
lower bounds on IPS imply VP not equal
vnp
um there were lots of things in there
you know at the time we thought we were
going to prove lower bounds on IPS and
it was going to be great that was in the
draft uh obviously that that turned out
to be much harder than we thought
um
uh but that was the earliest
um and then in February of 2014 uh I
gave a talk at Rutgers on it at the time
we didn't have the name I called it our
algebraic proof system and I listed
finding a better name as actually the
most important open question
um and uh Eric allender who I think is
is yes here with us online uh was there
and he suggested the name ideal proof
system uh which is of course you know a
great name I mean it's it's accurate
it's a proving things are in ideals uh
and of course for the pun and you know
just to give you a sense of like how
good this pun is I mean literally
yesterday the title of Russell's talk
used this pun right Tony patasi in
search of the ideal right uh yeah so
thanks thanks art for that
um and Eric also asked us this question
that Sam talked about in his talk which
was
you know okay you can you can do
verification of ips using polynomial
identity testing
um we don't know if extended Fraga
simulates IPS but what if polynomial
identity testing was sort of extended
Fraga provably easy then does extended
Fraga simulate IPS
um and Andy Drucker actually also asked
us this question uh around the same time
and it turns out that yes it does okay
and now for this next part of the story
uh you may have noticed there's a little
Gap here I need to fill that in so that
talk was on February 19th
um and we submitted to Fox on April 2nd
so all of this uh this whole part of the
paper really happened in that five weeks
and it was a very intense five weeks
um and this part I couldn't find a
record of but I'm fairly certain so that
in there's there's also a part of the
story here I'm pretty sure that the fox
deadline uh this I looked up was 4 30
P.M
uh and I'm pretty sure we submitted at
um and here uh I actually have an image
to go along with this um and I'm sort of
curious uh if Tony recognizes this image
Tony do you ring any bells
oh so I hear it's a keyboard and I have
no idea what it is uh okay yeah no
that's fine so yeah this is the keyboard
that I had at the time and it's I still
have it actually and it's one of these
keyboards with spring-loaded things and
so when you type on it it makes these
very satisfying but very loud clackety
clackity sounds
and you know at the time so I was in an
office my postdoc office it didn't have
Windows directly to the outside but uh
it had one of these high up Windows uh
up above where you couldn't see through
it but it would let light through into
Steve Cook's office who of course had
windows to the outside so I got some
natural light in there and I just I have
this very distinct memory of Tony and I
hunched over the computer with me
furiously typing away at this at this
very loud keyboard uh rapidly correcting
some of our final proofs before we
submitted at the last minute
um so yeah it was a was a very intense
five weeks but um yeah it was good
um okay and then after that uh you know
there was lots of follow-up work on this
um so Forge field at Samurai and
wigerson got lower bounds on cips for
some small circuit classes C by sort of
powering up algebraic circuit lower
bounds that we were already known for c
um and that was kind of exactly Our Hope
right is we've now got single functions
maybe we can prove lower bounds on them
uh Lee semorette and Wang characterize
ordinary Fraga up to quasi-poly as being
equivalent to a non-commutative version
of ips
uh and their proof actually follows are
or you know sort of going back to Eric's
suggestion
to show that the um the Raj vilka pit
algorithm for non-commutative formulas
was provably correct within Friga right
um and then Alexia Gregory of hersham
Samurai introduced The Cone proof system
which is a version of ips for
semi-algebraic proofs and then there
were a bunch of other other follow-up
Works
um and also this one uh so this is this
is me and Tony actually in our in our
Journal paper we mentioned a preprint
that we really had every intention of of
posting
um about getting an improved depth
preserving simulation
um and this was before we had uh lower
bounds on bounded depth algebraic
circuits
um and so at the time improving the
depth of our reduction seemed really
important now we have lower bounds on
arbitrary depth algebraic circuits and
maybe it seems less important to
optimize that particular parameter but
like you know we should still really
probably publish this at some point Tony
it's yeah
okay so now I I mentioned you know these
papers of Tony's from the 90s and I want
to come back to these because
um there are some other things I want to
highlight here so in her 96 and 98
papers the 98 was uh her based on her
talk at the ICM
um she introduced what we now know are
things that are equivalent to various
versions of ips but philosophically the
idea was there was like let's consider
the algebraic circuit size of these
nostalenshot certificates
um and in the 98 paper it was let's look
at the number of lines in a PC proof
um and that turns out to be equivalent
to a version of ips where you measure
complexity according to determinental
complexity
um so these were there
um but the other thing that was there
that I really want to highlight is
um you know I think one of the marks of
a real leader in a field is not just oh
they produce great results you know
Tony's mentored all these people she
organizes things and so on
um she also produces really great
questions
um and I don't know the exact history so
I don't know how many of these originate
with her or were sort of in the air but
I'm going to call them you know it's
Tony's birthday I'm gonna call them
Tony's questions
um so in these two papers there are
there are a great number of these
questions so a bunch of them were
resolved um so you know closing uh root
n versus ngap for PC degree of
pigeonhole principle
uh was a root n the right Bound for
pigeonhole principle when there's a very
large number of pigeons where in
principle it should be easier so rasprov
a couple years later answered both of
these in the negative that that linear
was really the right bound
um I know Stellan sots lower bound on
random three cnfs uh that was a couple
years later by Ben Sasson and pagliatso
[Music]
um
uh
uh you know she didn't call it IPS at
the time of course because that was
Eric's contribution uh much later but uh
you know she asked does extended fragrp
simulate IPS
um and actually this is a result that I
announced at a meta complexity Workshop
uh last year that should appear in the
archive shortly that if this happened
this would imply that at least that pit
is an NP so maybe not fully
randomization but still you know we we
our current methods seem very far from
even this level of Dr randomization so
maybe you know probably the answer is
yes but it seems hard
uh tightening the degree bounds of the
simulation of resolution by PC this I
actually don't know what the current
state of the art is I'm sort of curious
if if anyone in the audience knows what
the
the current state is here
um or maybe we could talk about it after
as
okay all right I'll keep going uh and
one was his cutting planes be simulated
by PC and sublinear degree and here it
turns out to be incomparable but I
couldn't quite dig up the reference in
time uh but I did find this great thing
that if you don't know about you should
know about um which is Mark vignol's
um made a publicly available
crowdsourced proof complexity Zoo so
this picture is from that website uh you
see sort of all the proof systems you
know and love here so frega extended
Fraga cutting planes resolution and so
on
um and if you dig into it
um in here it has this presumably you
know made in a sort of automated fashion
that cutting planes is incomparable with
polynomial calculus so I couldn't quite
chase down all these references but but
it certainly uh seemed right to me
um okay so back to our list of questions
and then a relationship between degree
and number of monomials in polynomial
calculus uh so this was resolved I think
in the way that Tony had asked it
uh by impagliato putlock and Segal in 99
that's a different IPS here uh but these
kind of trade-offs actually you know
there have been even results in the last
few years on on extending these
trade-offs and refining them and so on
um so yeah continues to be a very very
interesting area these were the
questions somebody asked that were
resolved but now I want to talk about
the questions that are still open
so one is
does low degree IPS simulate extended
fragrance right we said you seem to need
High degree
um probably the answer is you really do
need High degree but you know prove it
okay and this strikes me as a very
interesting question because it it's not
exactly a strong circuit lower bound
it's just a degree lower bound
and so like it seems like you know that
I don't see any big obstacle to being
able to prove this but probably proving
it would be pretty interesting and might
have some interesting methods in it
another one was getting PC to work well
in sat for sat in practice right in
theory it should work well
um in practice uh it just you know it
can't compete with modern cdcl solid
um although you know Noriko told us
yesterday about some work in this
direction but that was you know using
algebraic reasoning for algebraic
problems whereas here we really wanted
to compete on Sat
and of course the big question you know
ac02 Fraga or ac0p Fraga lower bounds
um now that question I think is is
probably quite a bit older but Tony had
a very interesting suggestion that I
think deserves uh further a further look
which is um with uh Alexis Maciel
um she proved a quasi-poly reduction to
depth 3 which is uh where you have a a
threshold you know Fraga Fraga proofs
where every line looks like a threshold
gate followed by mod P Gates followed by
and Gates
uh and that threshold gate is sort of
looking it's the equivalent of like
looking at probabilistic polynomials and
so Tony suggested looking at something
like PC proofs or now we might also say
IPS proofs over probabilistic
polynomials um and like sounds great
like yeah let's do it
um and then in the 98 paper uh she
mentioned a few more
um so there are some results by itai and
krycek and also Sauron Reese and a few
others using representation Theory to
prove
um
lower bounds uh uniform lower bounds on
PC
um
and you know at the time she said that
the deserves further study I guess I
don't know if she still feels that way
but I feel that way so great
um
uh and she was actually bold enough to
make a conjecture
which was uh if IPs over a finite field
is p-bounded for sat then NP equals
column p
and the interesting thing here is the
obvious way of doing this is to say well
uh we want some conditions under which
IPS becomes cook Reco but we now know
that that involves de-randomizing pit
but maybe you could actually prove this
conjecture unconditionally getting
around pit right that there are some
indirect connection where because of the
structure of the equations you get from
a SAT formula you know if IPs over a
finite field foresat is p-bounded then
somehow you do some indirect thing and
you can conclude NP equals co-np even
though the IPS proof itself was not
verifiable deterministically
and then the last one is uh is there a
natural proof select barrier for proof
complexity right which uh of course you
could ask in general but also even for
AC 0p Fraga right like is this a partial
explanation for why it's been so hard to
get these lower rounds
okay
um all right so in my last a few minutes
here
um I want to move on to uh more recent
work that I've done with Tony so this is
Joint with Tony uh nicolaga Lacy another
former Pro Stock of Tonys and Adrian she
a student of Tony's uh to appear on the
archive momentarily and actually Tony I
realized as I was making this slide I'm
pretty sure I owe you an email about
this
um you should consider this first line
here that's the email because yeah
um
all right so uh
you know I only have a few minutes so I
don't want to get into too much detail
but
um tensor isomorphism is is a is a
linear algebraic isomorphism problem
where if you do it over a finite field
and you list things out it's easier than
graph isomorphism and as a bottleneck to
improving it
um and if you do the succinct version
where you write things in terms of bases
it's at least as hard as graph
isomorphism and there are lots of
algebraic problems that are that are
equivalent to tensor isomorphism so ring
isomorphism uh local equivalence of
quantum States and and dozens of others
um
and uh
yeah so
um there's there's another story here
which is uh so I gave a talk about some
other results about tensor isomorphism
at Banff in 2019 uh where Tony was
and you know I asked the audience okay
here are some two small tensors two by
two by two are these tensors isomorphic
and you know I think I think it was
Russell actually who who sort of said no
they're not like you know I did the
calculation in my head and I can walk
you through it
um okay and then on my slide I had this
little thing here of like well how would
you prove in general the two tensors are
isomorphic is there some proof complex
safe in here this this little uh Point
here that was aimed at Tony this was
this was me trying to trick her into
working on this eventually
and uh yeah so that you know it took a
few years but but that worked so three
years later you know we finally worked
on it and got some results here
um all right so our main results we've
got a linear lower bound on PC degree
for tensor isomorphism uh for bounded
rank tensors we get a bounded degree PC
proofs
um and then the other thing
uh is you know linear algebra is sort of
a key tool in understanding tensors so
we we started to look at these basic
linear algebra pencils principles some
of which uh Sam mentioned in his talk so
one is Matrix rank uh another is uh if
you have ba equals I for square matrices
mathematically we know that a b equals I
right B is a inverse but the question is
can you prove this so This is called the
inversion principle uh we showed that
neither of these could be done in
sublinear degree
and our conjecture is that if you
augment PC with the power to prove uh to
do substitution instances of this
inversion principle for free that that
can't solve tensor isomorphism either
but this is wide open I mean we don't
know how to prove lower bounds on this
system for for any formula let alone
tensor isomorphism
um but it strikes me as a very
interesting thing that sort of mixes
linear algebra and and algebraic
reasoning in a in a sort of interesting
way
um and the other open question we left
is could you get a stronger lower bound
so you know in proof complexity
particularly from the Boolean World
we're used to thinking of n o of n as an
upper bound because you have Boolean
axioms like x i squared equals x i you
can always make things multilinear
um here you can phrase tensor
isomorphism purely algebraically you
don't need Boolean axioms to to phrase
it sort of faithfully and the obvious
upper bound is not n when you do that
the obvious upper bound is like 2 to the
N squared and so you might hope that you
could really get a much stronger degree
lower bound here
um and that would be pretty interesting
because I think it would be somewhat
different than
um you know a lot of the other PC lower
bound techniques that we have
okay
um so just to wrap things up uh one
thing of course uh you know I wanted to
highlight uh Tony's open questions from
96 98
um
uh you know I think this was obvious but
it's worth stating Tony is of course
still at the Forefront of proof
complexity
um and the the big open question here is
really um what will she trick us into
working on next so uh thanks and uh
Happy Birthday Tony
thanks thanks to us uh
comments
questions
uh hello oh uh Edo hi yes let's go ahead
and just ask yeah
yes thank you so uh uh hi uh
uh Josh yes I wanted to ask about uh one
of your remarks about uh uh if have
extended Fraga simulates IPS then pit is
in NP now this was already uh
um this basically uh implied by
definition
uh so right yeah and actually I have to
deal with this in my write-up of the
paper yeah because I know you have a
comment on one of your papers uh right
so it's implied by definition
um if you think of ips as a proof system
for
unsatisfiable systems of polynomials the
part that's not immediately obvious is
if you want to do it for tautologies
um uh yes oh I see I see yes correct
right so that's that's the result that
that's the remark I was really making is
even if you do it for Boolean
tautologies uh you still get that that
pit has to be an NP and that that
requires a little more work
uh yes by bitter arithmetizing the
circuits I presume yes exactly yep okay
yeah okay thank you
yeah uh really cool talk thank you uh
just a question I've heard of several
results recently about lower bounds
for IPs using things that are not
expressible
at CNS can you comment on what you think
about you know power of ips versus
things that are just direct translations
of Sienna formulas versus Power of IPs
over the gigantic languages you can talk
about yeah so uh right this is a great
Point actually as far as I know uh I
think all of the lower bounds that we
know for various restricted versions of
ips are not on the translations of
Boolean tautologies they're on other
systems of polynomial equations
um and actually this is this is one of
my favorite things I love talking with
Tony about
um is is uh yeah how
you know is there something in the
structure of the equations that you get
when you take the algebraic translation
of a Boolean tautology where you could
take advantage of that and like is IPS
actually much better at proving those
than proving General polynomials
um and we we don't know but it's a great
question yeah um and as far as I know
like I said all the all the lower bounds
we know for restricted versions of ips
are not on the translations of Boolean
tautologies yeah
thank you
any other questions
all right so uh let's thank Josh again
and reconvene again at 11 30.
foreign